all right
okay um
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
let's go over some logistics uh first
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to meet and
ask
otherwise please your use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in q a session at the end
second
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
today will be recorded
all right that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host peter banner who
is a director of max planck institute of
dynamics of complex technical systems
meghdaberg the germany
since 2003 he has been a professor for
mathematics in industry and technology
with
the tu
chemnitz
since 2011 he has also been an honorary
professor with the otto von
gurvik
university of derberg
germany he is a scion fellow
class of 2017
he received a diploma in mathematics
from the al wth aiken university in
germany in 2000
no 1993
from 1993 to 1997 he worked toward the
phd at the university of kansas
lawrence and u.s
and the tu chemnis
jikao germany where he received a phd in
mathematics in february 1997. in 2001 he
obtained the
habilitation in mathematics from the
university of braman germany
he was an assistant professor with the
university of brandman germany from 1997
to 2001 after spending a
term as a visiting associate professor
with the tu
amber cam
the germany he was a lecturer in
mathematics with the teu
berlin from 2001 to 2003.
all right uh his research interests
include scientific machine learning and
computing numerical
mathematics systems theory and optimal
control a particular emphasis that has
been on applying methods from numerical
linear algebra and matrix theory
in systems and control theory recent
research focuses on numerical methods
for optimal control of systems modeled
by evolution equations
model order reduction krylov subspace
methods for structured or quadratic
eigen problems
and using machine learning for
identifying dynamical systems
researching in all these areas is
accompanied by the development of
algorithms and mathematical software
suitable for modern and high performance
computer architectures today
peter will present an interesting topic
which is identification of nonlinear
dynamical systems from
noisy measurements
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further due let me pass the
button by asking one random question as
usual since peter is from germany
what is your favorite things to do in
germany
after answering that question see you
can um stage will be yours
visiting uh football games of bayern
munich
ah okay so you're the fan of the fire
munich okay that's awesome i had a good
night last night for those who are
following
day one
okay nice nice okay the stick is yours
okay thank you susan thanks for the nice
introduction and i'm not sure what i
should say thank you for um
raising the expectations so high as you
did
yeah this talk is um
joint work with pawan who spoke in this
seminar earlier this year in a way it is
a continuation of of his work um
and i should say that um power did most
of the technical work here in this this
uh
what i present today and he's he's
around so
i hope he can ask the
nasty technical questions that will come
up at the end of the talk
certainly but i will do my best to
explain the material and to show you
what we've been doing
um
just move this speaker
window a little bit so you can see my
own screen better okay so
before i go into the talk i would like
to acknowledge
some research funding they were
supporting this research partially the
one is
from a research training school of the
german national science foundation the
dfg which is called mathematical
complexity reduction and the second is
the
big mugs it's a max planck research
network and big data driven material
science
it's not so much related to the topic of
the talk but
this when we started this network that
yeah tracked me into uh looking into
machine learning more than we did before
that and uh parwan was higher than this
network as a postdoc
after he did this
he graduated and um
yeah he has been driving
you know the driver's seat and um
machine learning in my department for
the last three years
um yeah so today's
talk is uh following this line of
research
so i think the identification of
dynamical systems from data
is something that
[Music]
has
inspired generations of researchers and
systems and control theory early
i should have actually added this slide
here early
works you can find already in the 1960s
interestingly you can find even a
textbook from 1996 about using
artificial neural networks for
identifying dynamical systems from jose
van der waller and
barton moore and
a third author which may have just
missed but of course in 1996 they did
not have the machinery the hardware to
make use of really deep neural networks
so this topic was a little bit neglected
for 20 years
and received renewed interest since deep
learning and
yeah machine learning as a more general
area of research
has gained so much popularity
the the age of
discovering nonlinear systems
[Music]
is i think just blossoming even though
there is a lot of literature and
research and liquids are available
from the last three decades in their
software and so on but a lot of
challenges remained and one of the
challenges is how to deal with
noisy measurements and
how
to provide
data for the training and so on so we'll
focus a little bit on these topics and
try to
add a few
bits and pieces to the tool set of of
methods to identify
non-linear dynamics from measurements
okay so
this is the outline of the talk i will
just briefly introduce the topic i think
talks in this direction have been given
quite a bit in this seminar series so
i will not
start with adam and eve but
basically start where
r1 left
a couple of months ago
we will then formulate the working
hypothesis of the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
approach the cindy approach
that was popularized by nathan kutz and
stephen brunton a couple of years ago
and um
we will focus on one issue with this
approach and
um suggest a new variant uh which we
call a rumor cutter cindy will become
obvious why it's called
i will give you some extensions of the
approach or
show how it works on several benchmark
examples that are also used in the
penis paper by nathan and stephen and
some other
examples as well and we also look at
just a few extensions
the approach
and in the end we will add a higher
level of noise and that
means we will have to use it with
slightly different approach but it's
blended into this talk because it also
is based on uh using the the same roller
cutter scheme that we use in the um
all right so um just as a teaser
dynamical processes are omnipresent in
computational science and engineering
you see three
pictures of typical processes on the
right on the bottom you see a cfd
simulation around the
[Music]
turbine
you see a
micro circuit or nano circuit
in the middle and the top this is
actually an example from our own
institute where we also have engineering
departments we have four departments i'm
the mathematician and then there are
three engineering departments and this
is batch an example of batch
chromatography which is a non-linear
coupled system of partial differential
equations describing the separation of
two
products from a from a liquid
we'll not use this example here in this
talk but i have used it quite a bit on
model reduction talks that we gave on
production it's it's an interesting
problem
we
assuming now that we do not have
a model for the process that we are
studying but we
assume that we can measure any of these
things that we have here for instance
you can you know what you feed into a
and b
and you know what you you measure what
you extract
um at the end
so this is the
um the mix the mixture and this is then
the separated liquids that you can
measure at the end
and you can take time serious on how
much of the liquid of the a you get at
a certain point how much of the b
you want to find the mathematical model
because why do you want to do that you
want to
design a controller to attenuate
disturbances
of your potentially optimized process if
it's not optimized yet you may want to
optimize it with mathematical
optimization which also again needs a
model in order to apply optimization
algorithms and you may also want to be
able to predict the future behavior for
instance for the turbine if it's the
turbine of your boeing 747 that we're
hopefully all using soon again
um you want to know when it breaks right
um and you want to know that in advance
to take measures
to land safely so this these are these
are the motivations of finding
models from data of dynamical systems
some of them
so the general setup we will be using in
this talk mostly is
just an autonomous non-linear dynamical
system
with time derivative it's denoted by x
dot and the vector field describing the
right hand side
as f f x
and then you can find in the literal of
course many um
neural network approaches to
yeah provide
the output
or the dynamics of the system
from measured data and those
recurrent neural networks being used for
this long short time memory networks
that
roughly require no prior knowledge on
the physics of the process
they are not always possible
as possible as you would like them to be
to be used in this in control and
optimization
you don't get governing equations
directly from them
i mean that can be worked in and this is
basically where this what i'm talking
about
um converges to
these approaches or with these
approaches also
and they do not all too often not well
generalize outside the area where they
are trained that's the
good old generalizability problem of
neural network approaches
so um we are following here the uh path
of
making some hypothesis
that allows us to identify actually
model equations and
this path
is
essentially what is known
in the community nowadays as cindy as i
already said uh by uh
popularized
uh by by nathan and stephen and um added
with a lot of features and so on
the basic idea is um
that
we assume that the function f the vector
field f
can be described by
a small number of terms of nonlinear
functions
and
the idea is now to to build a dictionary
of candidates
from which we pick
uh terms that
at the end of the day give us an f that
can describe the data that we have
mentioned
and such as such a feature dictionary
which we will call
capital phi of x
could look like that so it will have
polynomials
up to a certain degree so this would be
all the polynomials that have degree two
as an example given below
if
if our state we have n states so the
state vector x has n components to
potential possible polynomials would be
x 1 square x 1 x 2
x 2 x 1 is the same so it would not be
added here x1 x3 x1 x4 and so on and
then you go all the way up to xn square
you do the same for cubics
quintix quartix whatever you want to
what you think you need there's a little
bit of
that that's actually the shortcoming of
this approach you would have to have an
idea which kind of terms
you need in order not to make the the
dictionary too
too thick basically
exponential functions trigonometric
functions you put in what you like
and then
the vector
psi is the vector that picks
the features from your dictionary that
at the end of the day define your
function f that you need to describe the
dynamics
the so the challenge now is first of all
you have to define your dictionary
and i'm assumed that this
that this is given in some sense
um
and we want to compute the vector psi
so this is um this basically this idea
is
brought into the engineering
world i think
maybe first in the paper by bungard
libsyn in
and it was formalized and extended in
the zindy work by by
procter and cuts
appearing in penis in 2016.
[Music]
so how do we get the psi we compute it
by
solving this minimization problem
[Music]
which
already shows where we have the
difficulty in this approach or one of
the difficult pieces we need data for
the derivative x dot
and
well
there was a remark that the libsyn paper
has a different approach of course the
approach is different but it uh
i think it's this is an idea to
reverse engineer a function from data
and doing that with
a number of features let's put it let's
keep it on this basis here
data
so it might be for several reasons might
be difficult to get good data for the
derivative
numerical differentiation
could be used i mean of the data
based on the data that you have in your
time series but we know that this is
often doesn't give good good results
also of course the construction of the
rich enough feature dictionary
allows efficient
is important and
there we hopefully have some idea on the
physics that we want to
model
some domain knowledge that helps us to
to find a good dictionary say
and for the derivative data we want to
suggest an approach
that
is based on
using
an idea from numerical analysis what
that
that we all know from our first class in
numerical analysis
that can be used to solve ordinary
differential equations the roon cutter
scheme but here it's not used to solve
but it's used to
find a different minimization problem
that
that does not require um to
find derivative data from the time
series that we have available
um
so just as a
spot recollection of your
undergraduate years
um
what is the wrong scheme given a
differential equation in the form that
we want to
basically identify
setting
we and given we have a function value of
the solution x at the
time t i we want to predict
uh the function x at time t i plus 1.
um
and then the rumor cutter scheme
is just one of many many many methods
that we learn all in undergraduate
school
um
it it uses
it's one of the explicit methods
that does not require solving nonlinear
systems to
compute x of t t i plus one it's just
using a weighted sum of the vector field
um
evaluated at specific locations
think
often these are called this computing
the stage derivatives so usually you
compute
basically the the vector field
at
points between or you approximate the
vector field at points between
e i and t i plus 1. here's how it looks
like precisely
everybody remembers it's this weighted
sum of these stage derivatives where k1
is just the function evaluated at e i
and so on
um
and then you get an approximation of
x of t i plus 1.
it
has um
an error that is in
uh behaves like h
to the power four so this is nice
um
it doesn't have very good stability
properties when solving stiff
differential equations but this is not
the focus here
the focus will be to
make use of it in the in within the
cindy approach and the notation that we
will be using for this formula here
will be this capital f with the archive
for
identifying
identifying the the fourth order
explicitly classical wrong
scheme
so um the only i mean the issue is here
of course we cannot
apply it here in our context to the data
because uh
the function f is not known this is what
we want to identify right so
cannot
use this this scheme per se but
we know that we we have our working
sparsity hypothesis so we apply the
rumor cutter scheme for our
answers yeah but
phi of x times psi
times the
selection vector that selects the
features from the dictionary
so
we have we put in our working hypothesis
or component wise it looks like this
and
so we would get in in
component wise this equation and this is
what the standard cindy approach would
would now use if
derivative information is provided
so but we
want to use the archive 4 scheme and
this means
we use
[Music]
sorry
okay
we use the following we
with the help of the akka4 scheme our
data
our time series data would
have to
satisfy
this equal in this equality if it were
produced by archive 4 but it's it's
usually not the case we don't know how
it is
provided but that we know that the akka
4 scheme would be a good approximation
of the time evolution
if at least if the step size is small
enough
okay so we um insert now in our archive
4 formula our representation of the
function f
that is represented now by our
dictionary and our selection vector
and um
we make the evaluations in the archive 4
scheme based on the
sparse hopefully sparse if these sigma
vectors are sparse
representation of our function
and this would lead then um
in a well
a visual way to a procedure like that um
you start with you have input data
that's your
your state at time ti
you feed it into your um
uh yeah
representation feature
map
representation
and then apply the necessary steps in
the room cutter schemes to get at the
output
x1 now of course we don't know the um
the sparse vector or the the
selection vector side is what we want to
compute so this now gives us
the following regression problem that
looks like this yeah so we have
the task to determine
the sparsest possible
psi vectors minimizing this problem so
that the data would follow the
roomakuta4 evolution
um as we all know
this this is an
impressive sensing problem that is np
hard to find the l0
minimizer
so we do the usual thing we do the
one norm relaxation
um by appending
this relaxation term
and we all know we know that this often
even gives you the fastest possible
vector under the rrp property
that we but that we may not have here
but at least we get something close by
um
what we then do is we use
the similar the same sequential
thresholding algorithm that was
suggested in the paper by
uh stephen brunton and nathan kutz
just applied now for this regression
problem
presenting problem
that
that we have formulated it's slightly
differently from the original paper
where
you would have to use the derivative
information that we not do not employ
so here's just this thresholding
algorithm
we solve the lasso problem one
find the
indices
that are
below a certain threshold lambda set
them to zero then with the
indices that the the the components of
the sigma vector set to zero we solve
the optimization problem again
and
loop until the error
is
small enough
until the convergence is
is established so that we do not get any
improve
um
and then we take this this um
these this uh computed selection vectors
um and
pick the and the corresponding elements
from our dictionary dictionary to define
the function
um
so this is this is basically the
procedure so it's um
[Music]
similar in a sense then then what is
done in the standard cindy just we have
replaced
this optimization problem
from the originals in the approach but
this one based on the rumor cuda scheme
still a non-linear non-convex
optimization problem
for the computation we use a
gradient-based optimization for instance
atom
is now popular in the machine learning
days
we use
for the gradient computation approach
implemented in pytorch
for finding lambda that's also i think
already suggested in the
the cindy paper we use a
cross-validation approach
and let me see let us see how this works
the first example is from the original
paper it's a
cubic oscillator
a cubic temp oscillator it's a
two-dimensional
very simple
differential system of differential
equations so it has
the only terms in the right hand side
are all cubic
[Music]
the feature dictionary that we use in
this test contains all the polynomials
up to degree five
and we compare our approach with the
standards in the approach and this is
what we get so this is uh these are
face spaces
of the solutions
of the clean data in red and the
standards in the in dotted line and the
our approach in the
black
connected line
and you see that for small
time serious data with small kind of
small step size i should say that the
training data was
obtained with
adaptive ode solver of order four five
so um
it's not not at all related um to the
rumor cutter scheme that we use in the
identification
you see that for small enough depth step
sizes both approaches are able to
identify the dynamics quite well
but if if you make the step size
large enough you can see that
the standards in the approach becomes
unstable while we are still are able to
approximate the dynamics quite well and
you can see the reason
in this table
for them let's just look at the last
row where we have the largest step size
or
used
we are still identifying a model
with um
only cubic terms in the right hand side
with our approach
and a little bit of
error in the coefficients compared to
the original model
but the standards in the approach using
the same threshold values in the
iterative thresholding
does also insert
quadratic terms
and also
a quintic term here for instance and
here into the model and this at the end
of the day
leads to the larger errors already for
the next larger
next smaller step size
0.05
we see that
cindy does identify
terms in the
right-hand side the vector field that
are not present in the clean proof
ground proof model
all right so that was um
happy to see that that our approach was
able to deal with this
we also tested fitzyu nagumo which is an
example that we often use for testing
non-linear model reduction method it's a
very simple and basic model for the
spiking of a neuron in your in the brain
um
here it's a even a simplified version of
that uh the
you know
model reduction we often have uh the
first equation
um spatially it was um distributed so
that is a pde
um but here we have a cubic term in the
original model
and again the feature dictionary that we
use contains the polynomials up to
degree five we do the same comparison
we see again that for the
largest step size
cindy's starts to deviate from the
ground roof
while we are still able to
follow the ground group very nicely with
the
akka 4 or aka casindi approach then you
see that
for the larger
step sizes
cindy identifies terms that are not
present in the original model while we
that basically only those terms that are
also present in the ground group
um
okay
so extensions we can add parameters to
our description of the dynamics so we
play a little trick here that that we
augment our states by the parameters to
define a new state variable x mu and
then we append also the right hand side
because this is for type for
parameters that do not vary with time so
their time derivative is zero so the
augmentation of the vector field is easy
and this is not something we do
we would not need to identify if we
do this immediately
and then we also add
polynomial or say features of mu
in the dictionary
we test this here for an example that is
also often used in the
cindy and sparse identification
literature as the parametric normal form
which
exhibits
bifurcations depending on the parameter
mu
here
we
look at
data
that we
corrupt
corrupt artificially by a very small
tiny fraction of
gaussian white noise
to see how robust this is with respect
to little proto-patients
dictionary this time we only added
polynomials up to degree three
and we see that um akasindi is also
able for the
on the test set of the
parameters
for which we have no data collected
to reproduce the solutions
in face space
quite nicely
again for herefore
we see that
the archive for cindy discovers a more
parsimonious model than the standard
cindy approach and there's also again
a few terms here in the standards in the
approach that are
not present in the ground so
our approach shows a little bit of
advantage here as well
we can also do rational functions on the
right hand side which is important in
this example that i showed you from the
process engineering from separating of
chemicals
you usually have
rational terms in the model descriptions
so if we have data we would expect that
we want to
identify also rational functions
now if your ground rule for instance
would have such a rational right hand
side you would have to put that into
your feature space
to identify it essentially
or this this this term
which of course as you don't know what
the the the
rational functions involved in the
right-hand side you cannot do and you
cannot
uh yeah do this for many many values of
the of a parameter for instance in front
of the x term here in denominator
so what we do in this this case is um
we expand our approach to allow for two
sparse selectors
and we apply them in the denominator and
in the enumerator
so that we have two different
representations
as one would do also often in other
computations with rational functions
um
so we would
say if you assume that this is a
rational function we would identify a
sparse polynomial
in the enumerator and the sparse
polynomial in the denominator
and we have tested this for the
like michaelis-menten
kinetics equation which
in the easiest
form
for an enzyme dynamics looks for
instance like this
and
we use different
initial values
to get the training trajectories
and then we learn the model with our
rational archive for akasindi approach
and
what we show here is so this is the
range where the
initial values of the training data were
and this this is outside the training
range so these are
the initial conditions
that we have not our not trained our
model on
and we can see that
for this simple example at least we get
a generalizable
model from the data
that works well
outside its training which regime
okay
so far let's see where are we with time
we have presented
say
added
a little bit of
yeah
a different approach to deal with the
problem of using um
derivative data in the in the zindy
approach
the scheme that we propose does not
require any estimate of derivatives
um
uh
of course the as with all dictionary
learning approaches
um the quality um
depends highly on the
quality of the dictionary
and we also see that
this approach or we saw it at least in
one example
behaves rather robustly in the presence
of small noise
up to five percent i think
we saw in the examples that it's working
still quite well but beyond that
we
see that as an issue
and this approach will also not work
anymore
so
we looked into this problem more
recently
this is rather new work that was just
i think submitted last week or the week
before to the archive
and
to deal with the noise we
we make now use of
ideas from neural networks
but combine it again with with the
archive 4 scheme that we have been using
in the cindy approach as well so this
connects the two approaches
so how is this done
the first step is
to learn to find an implicit
representation of our data
so
this is done by a straightforward
feedforward neural network
that takes time as the input and that
takes
the state
at the out as the output and then we
compare it to the
noisy measurement as a loss function and
we learn essentially the
uh the implicit representation
so this this filters should filter the
noise
um
of course we need to regularize because
otherwise the network would overfit and
we do this again with a room cutter
scheme
so
we again
know that this is a time series that
comes from a differential equation and
the rumor cutter scheme is able to
approximate the time the
evolution of a new of a dynamical system
so these the time series should and the
output of
the roon cutter schemes should be close
by
and so we we filter essentially this
data again
by uh requiring that it follows that the
evolution that the
scheme would predict
of course for that we also need the
right hand side for our dynamical syst
in order to make use of the rumor cuda
scheme and this because we don't know
anything else at the moment
we also
represent by another neural network so
the whole approach looks like that we
take the noisy time series data
we
find an implicit representation
for the
for this time series using this first
neural network
then um
we
run this through the wrong cutter scheme
which requires another neural network to
represent the non-linear the vector
field the nonlinear dynamics the right
hand side
and
yeah and at the end of the day we get an
implicit representation of the
of the denoised data as well as of the
dynamics
and how is the learning process
controlled it's controlled by the loss
function so that our implicit
representation
should fit the data
at the same time the
the denoised data
should
follow
the dynamics
that is behind the process and that we
see that we
yeah get from the rumor cutter scheme
applied
to the other network whose parameters we
called phi so there's
parameters i think um
five you know
theta for the implicit representation of
the data and phi for
uh the dynamics and we also include um
the gradient loss here in the log in the
loss function we can do that because we
know that the
time derivative of our states
this would be represented by the neural
network we learned for the dynamics
and as we have the implicit
representation of the data
by this feedforward neural network we
can use automatic differentiation to get
derivative data for this implicit
representation so we can evaluate this
loss function and
so we have um and we have of course
these two weighting parameters to get
this representation
so with that we hope to be able to find
um a representation of the dynamics of
the time series
um
for
noisy measurements
and i should mention here that there is
no need for a
uniform
mesh on which this time series is
collected can also be sparsely collected
with
um
varying
variant time distance
uh so there's no assumption on the time
criteria
so here we we test again this is this
example for the fitsunagumo that we
already saw
we collect the data for a certain
initial condition and corrupt corrupted
by different noise levels
and what you see here is
let me see
this was just covering my
slide here um so this is the the top row
is for the noise level five percent so
little noise you see the
in green
that is a little bit of variance around
the ground roof the denoised
the clean data
and to see the denoised data
and here you see also in face space
noisy and the denoised data
and you see the vector field that we
identify with this neural network
approach
and then we crank up the noise level up
to 40 percent
so you see basically the the noisy data
and face base gives you a point cloud
from which you cannot see much
but um with our approach we are able to
uh find a model that produces these um
limit cycles
in the face space that we uh know
exists in the in the um
google model
even for this noise level of 40 percent
um
okay so this brings me already to the
end of the talk
um
what we have um i don't know it's not
quite the end sorry there's one more
point um
this approach that i just
showed demonstrated here for these
simple
ordinary differential data obtained from
ordinary differential equations
could be extended if we make the
assumption that the
data
that we measure is
[Music]
would be modeled or would come from a
model
that would require a partial
differential equation so this is this is
where we are currently at um
here we also have um the spatial to take
the spatial coordinates that we then
assume that they exist in the pde model
as uh inputs for this implicit network
in order to denoise the data
oops
and
yeah
the
neural network defined the vector field
here was modeled then using a cnn
that also makes use of the spatial
information and this is relatively new
thing that if you have a question on how
this is done exactly and
powerpoint will be happy to answer
so you see this approach working at work
for the purpose equation here
you see
an initial data that
statum that we often see in examples
a strong front in the initial condition
that fades out
with time
here we have noise level five percent so
this is not so much
um
here we go up to 20
you see that um the measurements it
looks already quite rough for this level
of noise and we see that the denoised um
solution here
denoise data it shows a little bit of
wiggles down here but it
the main features of the solution are
very well recovered
okay this is now the end of the talk um
what we have done is we have blended
cindy with a rumor cutter scheme to
avoid
derivative estimation
from the time series data
we have extended this to cover also
cases where we have additional design
stationary design parameters
or
want to discover
rational
non-linearities
we also have proposed an approach to
denoise the measurements and
simultaneously learn the dynamical model
which then is it
goes back to a black box scheme of
course
but we could use this denoised data then
with the cindy approach
uh with the aka cindy approach to
discover the
analytic equations if you wish this is a
next step that we
have
also to implement i suppose and test
and the other thing
is that we
also know
it's just an idea at this moment
that from the model reduction
world where many of us come from
that the solutions of pde models
often evolve in low dimensional
manifolds this is why model reduction
model reduction
um
uh based on reduced basis or so on is
successful
so how can we incu
make use of that in in this this
this approach
so yeah
okay
that's that's that's all um thanks for
your attention and here are
a few references that we have been using
in particular this is the the one
pre-print for the related to the first
part of the call it's been out for
a while
it's just recently
okay thank you so much peter uh that was
a wonderful talk um
and we do have a
several
questions let's start with a uh the
question from rob he asked
how is this compared to the use of
levenberg
markford as a simple feeding technique
well
i cannot say that because we haven't
done this comparison
i'm also not so much experienced with
the
different
different different techniques um
certainly something that we can that we
should that we should test in the in the
future yeah so i cannot really say
anything informed here because we just
haven't done
this on this level
okay the next question is by faye can
you show the effects
can you show the effects of the
denoising implicit
neural network by feeding the dynamical
neural network directly without it
i'm not sure whether i understood that
question please
right okay uh
um if if you cannot mute yourself and
verify that's right
so um my question is so if you just
finish
your noisy data with the dynamical
neural network without the the noising
step
um
yeah
don't think i mean in that case we would
not have
an easy way to
use the gradient loss i think
and that that might
not give
as smooth results as as the approach
that i showed
maybe maybe parvan if i don't know
whether you have done this these
experiments
in the course of the action um
say some anything here
probably if you can admit
um yes i think what what peter
just now said it i think the the
derivative if you if you don't miss
master derivative information like uh
with the one derivative which you get
from random and also one derivative
which you can get from the implicit
neural network if you don't mismatch
then there will be even more vegans
around basically
so i think this this part of loss is
also very important to to have
uh denoise data for if you have a large
amount of noise on the data
okay uh next question is by kodi uh have
you seen the paper on
archived paper by
fuja and alves
they used cindy to identify pdes in an
integral formulation from noisy
pic simulation data
in their case denoising did not work
well
i think they just tried gaussian
smoothing but the integral formulation
worked well
i must admit that i have not read that
paper so far so i it's hard for me to
comment on that
i'm not sure the power has
had a look at it but
i cannot i cannot say um
cannot comment on their work input
that's right whether this is an effect
that we will observe if we go to to
higher to more complicated pde models
it's of course hard to predict and that
that would be interesting to see and i
think if they um
we will have a look at this paper and
see what kind of um
examples they they use and we'll try it
with our approach whether we can uh
have to run into the same difficulties
or whether we
get something
better
it would be yeah that would be
definitely
interesting to see
right right okay next question is uh by
beta
is your rk full cindy approach also
applicable for finding the second order
dynamics
um
arcar 4 would probably not be the right
thing to do then
but there are of course
the akka4 can be
exchange for
any other integrator basically right
um so if we in if i would like to
identify a second order dynamics i would
then
[Music]
go make for instance to a leapfrog team
or whatever or new uh newmark method um
as the as the filter for this approach
yeah and i think that can be done here
but we haven't done that yet
okay
next question is by nathaniel he has the
classical problem with cindy is what
happens if your operator isn't easy to
guess a dictionary or a priory
you touched on this with rational
functions have you done any experiments
on your denoising strategy when the
dynamics to be learned can only be
approximated by the dictionary and not
exactly represented
now this this is also beyond our current
experimentation i think
unless uh taiwan has done anything any
thing in that regard in the last days
but that
yeah i mean
of course there's a hierarchy of
difficulties and we are
very low in that hierarchy at the moment
of the difficulties that you can add in
the identification
the identification process yeah
as i said it's the
um
[Music]
optimizing the choice of the dictionary
automatically i think is this is beyond
the work we have been doing and that
that is i think an important question
in order to make these these approaches
more successful even
yeah yeah okay
next question is by anders nice talk uh
have you tried your approach on a pure
wave propagation problem
um
[Music]
pure wave not i think it's all the
burgers is the damped wave in the sense
i think we can go to to rather low
viscosities with this approach
in comparison to some model reduction
approaches that get problems with
these viscosities
i would have to think about
well
[Music]
if you know that you have a pure
transport phenomenon in your problem
i think one would also need to take this
into account in the integrator that is
used in the scheme archive 4 wouldn't be
the the the choice there
but there are of course integrators that
are designed
to
stately reproduce
wave phenomena and
i think that would be from the
implementation side would be more
complicated also probably
computationally it would get a little
bit more involved but i think that that
could be done whether it really works i
cannot say at this moment but i would
recommend using a different integrator
nice nice okay uh next question is from
me
is okay cindy available as an open
source code
i think um
carbon can answer that i think it's a
github
available
yeah i think it's still not public maybe
in the next weeks it will be
okay since you guys just uh published in
the in the archive right yeah yeah okay
i'd like to see the open source quote um
once it is available in public okay i do
not see any more questions okay so
is there any other questions from
audiences
no
okay uh with that uh let's conclude uh
thank you so much for the great talk
peter uh it was it was really really
well done uh i learned a lot
so thank you so much
thanks to all the participants for
listening and for staying until the end
that's awesome it's it's a seven o'clock
for four in germany right yeah
okay all right
thank you again
with that we will conclude the seminar
today and we will see everyone uh in the
next ddps seminar until then uh stay
stay
safe
and see you next time okay bye bye bye
bye
okay bye